ya hablamos de que los enlaces son como
resortes pero hemos ignorado el momento
dipolar el momento dipolar afecta la
intensidad de la señal
veamos rápidamente un repaso cuando
tenemos un dipolo es decir dos cargas
opuestas separadas podemos decir que el
momento dipolar es igual a la magnitud
de la carga en nuestro dipolo delta
minúscula es una carga parcial por la
distancia entre las cargas entonces si
tenemos una carga parcial positiva
separada por una cierta distancia de una
carga parcial negativa como los enlaces
son como resortes aquí tenemos nuestro
resorte tenemos una magnitud positiva y
una negativa estas son nuestras cargas y
están separadas una distancia de así que
tenemos un momento dipolar si tenemos
una magnitud de cargas
paradas por una cierta distancia hay un
momento dipolar y si tenemos una
vibración de estiramiento es decir si
este enlace se estira la distancia
cambia y si cambiamos la distancia
entonces el momento dipolar también
cambia y esto es muy importante porque
solo las vibraciones de estiramiento que
producen un cambio en el momento dipolar
se pueden observar como señales en el
espectro y r veamos un ejemplo aquí
tenemos ciclohexano y sabemos que el
carbón y lo tiene un momento dipolar el
oxígeno es más electro negativo que el
carbono así que el oxígeno tiene una
carga parcial negativa y este carbono
tiene una carga parcial positiva como
tenemos un momento dipolar grande en el
carbón y lo esperaríamos ver una señal
fuerte para el estiramiento de
de doble enlace entonces si analizamos
el espectro separemos la región de
diagnóstico de la región de huella
dactilar observen que aquí tenemos una
señal muy fuerte pasando los 1.700
números de onda se encuentra
aproximadamente en 1715 y nos
encontramos en la región que corresponde
al doble enlace esta señal en nuestro
espectro corresponde al estiramiento del
doble enlace carbono oxígeno como éste
es parcial negativo y éste es parcial
positivo hay un momento de polar grande
significa que obtendremos una señal
fuerte por lo tanto si tenemos un
momento dipolar pequeño observaremos una
señal débil veamos un ejemplo y
comparemos los dos espectros y
ahora tenemos el espectro para el uno
externo entonces nuevamente dividamos
las dos regiones si analizamos la región
que corresponde al doble enlace nos
encontramos con esta señal que se
encuentra entre 1600 y 1700 podemos
decir que se localiza aproximadamente en
1650 entonces como esta señal se
encuentra en la región del doble enlace
corresponde al estiramiento del doble
enlace carbono carbon es decir este
doble enlace que tenemos en el uno
externo y observen que esta señal no es
tan intensa como la anterior esta señal
es más fuerte que ésta
y esta es una señal débil así que esta
señal no tiene un momento dipolar tan
fuerte
si pensamos en este doble enlace voy a
dibujar los hidrógenos para que sea más
fácil aquí tenemos un momento dipolar
pequeño porque este grupo alquilo es un
grupo donador de electrones y como no
tenemos una molécula simétrica tenemos
un momento dipolar débil así que no
tenemos una señal intensa más bien
tenemos una señal débil entonces la
señal super intensa de un carbón y lo
nos ayuda a saber que grupos funcionales
tenemos muy bien hagamos uno más
comparemos dos al que nos aquí tenemos
al 2 3 dimetil 2 wooten 1 2 3 423
dimetil 2 putter entonces primero
dibujemos nuestra línea en 1500 si
analizamos la región que corresponde al
doble enlace
ser ven que no tenemos ninguna señal y
eso es porque tenemos un al que nos
simétrico observen que tenemos los
mismos grupos en ambos lados del doble
enlace y como es un al que nos simétrico
no existe ningún momento dipolar así que
no hay un cambio cuando el doble enlace
carbono carbono se estira y por eso no
vemos una señal en el espectro esto es
algo muy importante si tenemos una
molécula simétrica no veremos una señal
en el espectro y r